That concludes our discussion
of the Fast Fourier Transform.
>From a practical perspective, probably
the most important thing to remember
from the lesson is that convolution
can be done in n log n time,
not n squared as one
might naively think.
Don't be needlessly intimidated by
the need to perform convolution in
an application.
And be aware that image and signal
processing libraries use this technique.
>From the perspective
of algorithm design,
the Fast Fourier transform falls
in the category of divide and
conquer algorithms, along with merge
sort and Strassen's algorithm for
matrix multiplication, for those who
are familiar with those algorithms.
It has some resemblance to dynamic
programming, too, however.
Instead of just having one problem,
we have multiple problems
as we want to evaluate
a polynomial at multiple values.
And the associated subproblems
overlap in a way captured by that
butterfly network.
The butterfly network, by the way, is a
fascinating structure in its own way and
it's sometimes used in
massively parallel computers.
It also serves as an important
example in graph theory.
Another thing to appreciate from
the lesson is the strange twists and
turns that our development
of the algorithm took.
We started by thinking about
the general problem of convolution,
but the algorithm came
much more specifically
from thinking about the special
case of polynomial multiplication.
We started by only considering
sequences of integers yet,
complex numbers became an essential
part of the algorithmic solution.
Sometimes the ideas you need
come from unexpected places.
So soak up as much
mathematics as you can.
You never know when it
might come in handy.